à l'autre bout de la planète on assiste
à un véritable bras de fer entre tous et
eux est la plus grande démocratie du
monde l'inde
alors qu'aux états unis twitter a
suspendu le compte d'al en club et ce de
plusieurs de ses sympathisants qui ont
pris d'assaut le capitole en aide
twitter a fini par céder aux demandes du
premier ministre narendra modi en
fermant des centaines et des centaines
de comptes hostiles au gouvernement
[Musique]
avec la voix bonjour bonjour alexis vous
êtes basé à mumbai mégapole indienne
expliquez-nous dans quel contexte le
premier ministre indien a demandé à tous
et eu de censure et ses centaines de
comptes twitter et ça arrive à un moment
où le pays est sous une vague de
manifestations des fermiers qui ébranle
le gouvernement indique ce que le
gouvernement dit c'est que derrière ces
mouvements des fermiers qu'il y aurait
des séparatistes 6 et il y aura aussi la
main du pakistan l'ennemi éternel de
l'inde qui sourient les médias sociaux
propagerait donc de la désinformation
contre l'inde
et c'est pour ça que on a demandé à
twitter de censurer certains comptes
twitter associé avec les gens qui
appuient ces manifestations et à travers
tout son art est un grand mot dit le
premier ministre à tout faire pour
convaincre twitter d'aller dans ce sens
là il ya même pris l'exemple de la chaux
du capitole à washington pour inciter
tous et à agir le 26 janvier dernier qui
était le jour de la république en inde
les fermiers ont avancé sur la capitale
delhi avec leurs tracteurs dans
l'objectif d'avoir une manifestation
pacifique
cela a dégénéré et le gouvernement a dit
en gros que c'était l'équivalent de ce
qui s'était passé au capitole et si à la
suite de ces incidents la qui ont fait
un mort qu'on a demandé à twitter de
bloquer quelques centaines de contenu ce
que twitter
au fait en premier lieu et parmi ceux-ci
avaient des comptes de médias reconnus
de journalistes reconnus aussi donc
twitter bloqué ses comptes parce que la
pression devenait
art de la part du gouvernement donc en
bout de ligne tout est eux cèdent à la
pression du gouvernement mais mais tous
les trucs très concrètement craignaient
les représailles de la part du
gouvernement
imaginez on ne bloquez finalement 97%
des comptes que le gouvernement voulait
bloquer selon la loi sur les
technologies de l'information et bien le
gouvernement peut demander aux vous
compagnies comme twitter de bloquer ses
comptes
et si la compagnie ne le fait pas et
bien et les ses employés risquent des
peines de prison deux qui vont jusqu'à
7,1 alors que vous imaginez que dans les
bureaux de twitter en aide
on a quand même eu un peu peur et en
somme me frédéric lavoie est ce que
l'avenir de twitter en est carrément
menacé twitter si la compagnie veut
demeurer en inde
eh bien elle va devoir faire des
compromis en ce qui a trait à la liberté
d'expression et il ya des fortes chances
finalement qu'elles doivent bannir
certains opposants sinon elle de quoi
quitter le pays
donc quitter le pays carrément et
pendant ce temps là il ya un nouveau
joueur indien qui profite de la
situation
oui coup ko à la compagnie existe depuis
un an elle était évidemment beaucoup
moins importante que twitter mais le
ministre du commerce a indien pour
répondre à twitter l'eau fait sur
l'application coup si jamais twitter
disparaît du paysage indien comme le
disparu récemment tik tok par exemple eh
bien peut-être qu'on va être tenté
d'aller vers l'option nationale coup et
frédéric il faut parler la résonance
internationale de ce bras de fer
ça n'a pas plu au gouvernement indien
notamment ses tweets de rihanna la
chanteuse et greta d'une berg ce qu'il a
fait en fait ceux qui le demandent et à
des célébrités indienne du joueur de
criquet d'une chanteuse très populaire
de films bollywoodiens de répondre sur
les réseaux sociaux à rihanna a great
attenberg en disant que voilà ce que
ceux qui étaient propagées par ces gens
de l'extérieur c'était une campagne
contre l'inde et qu'il fallait se tenir
debout pour défendre le
i frédéric lavoie merci d'avoir été avec
nos prochaines heures voire